good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesome thing that
you have inside you explode out into the
universe to have a major impact so to
help you on your journey today's message
is work joyfully over the youths a guru
[Music]
you can live life with ease
not with struggle one thing is when we
say work
it's a many young people wonderful
people who getting recognized for
whatever wonderful things they have done
leaving them apart but generally work
means always been people have been
taught that they must work hard nobody
told them they must work joyfully nobody
told them their work should be an
expression of their joy or their love
they have to work hard if you work hard
life will be tedious how will this how
else will it be you will do something
hard only because you don't know how to
do it if you know how to do it you do it
with ease so without learning how to do
something if we try to do it without
investing enough time and perception if
life is all expression then life becomes
a big struggle I have a list of beliefs
that I read every morning every single
morning I have a written on my computer
I pop it up and these are the lists of
beliefs and values that I want to remind
myself of that I want to live today and
every day and I find that reminding
myself of it in the morning helps make
sure that I actually follow through on
it during the day and so one of those
things that I read to myself every
morning is that work is play one of the
beliefs that I want to espouse on a
daily basis is that work is play that
work isn't just work that work isn't a
place to go and die at work isn't a
place to go and struggle and yes work is
a lot of hard work right work is a lot
of a grind work is a lot of
stuff done and checking a lot of things
off the list right you want to be
productive and feel like you're creating
meaningful value in the world today but
it doesn't have to suck like work can be
fun and it's partly enjoying the work
having passion for what you're doing
right doing something that you feel is
meaningful but also just having fun with
it and so if I look at some of the
things that I do you know in our office
environment I had Alex and Lily over and
they started breaking out into a song
and in the morning when I'm making
videos from my book you'll see me on
snapchat with you know rabbit ears a
raccoon ears or some fun filter on it
and fun is different to each person
right I'm not the guy who's gonna be out
cracking jokes that's maybe more Alex's
style but the point is that you're doing
the things that you can express your
creativity through that you are having
fun with if you are on your way to your
office whether your office is your
basement or your home office or an
actual office where you have your
employees and team members if you're on
your way to go and do work and you are
dreading it
like another day and it's like it feels
like the world is beating you down
you're not gonna create great work but
if you feel like you have to just plow
through a whole bunch of crap every day
it's not gonna feel fun
you're not gonna create an amazing
experience and so if you can approach it
with how can I have fun today it's just
asking that question how can I make this
fun it's not by taking breaks right it's
not by doing something in between to
break up the crap right it's not okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna grind through this
for two hours and then I'm gonna say I'm
gonna take a celebration and go grab a
coffee and then come back and then you
know grinds out some more it's like how
can you make the grind fun how can you
inject fun into the actual process so
that you are enjoying the process cuz
you can get to that point it's not that
every single minute of every day is
gonna be amazing but if you get to that
point where work is playing where work
is fun you're not just going to have
more fun but it's gonna show in the
result as well it's gonna show in what
you create you're gonna create better
things it's going to add more value it's
gonna help you grow your business much
more than if you go to work every day
feeling like the world
is crushing you down so the question
they today is I'm curious how do you
inject more joy into your work I'd love
to hear for you please share your
thoughts down the comments below I also
want to give a quick shout out to
Abhishek Dube thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book your one
word it really really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying the read
thank you guys again for watching I hope
you have an amazing day I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
[Music]
as I commit to happiness fully exactly
what I need is coming towards me because
I become a magnet I become an energy
field that is so magnetizing that is so
excited that's so inspired that other
people want to support and work with
that energy and so when we dwell in the
energy of joy and happiness we become a
magnet for that which we desire so my
hope for you all is to start to think
about the things that you want to
succeed in whether it's succeeding in
romantic relationships are succeeding in
your career or succeeding in your health
goals and make a commitment today to
bring more joy to that area of your life
rather than seeing it as a struggle
rather than pushing forward with all
this angst and negativity and neediness
and control just bring joy to it your
successes will come when you commit to
joy when you commit to happiness
so find more joy in that physical
exercise
I've been going to SoulCycle I
absolutely love it it's so joyful for me
and that's helping me raise my butt
because that was one of my goals and
success and and then we have these
moments where we want to really bring
joy into our career well if you're
having a hard time in the office just
find ways to have more fun and as we
start to elevate that presence of joy we
will begin to magnetize the successes in
our life and so take this very seriously
bring this practice into your day-to-day
experiences and make joy and happiness
your number one priority and recognize
how your successes will be brought to
you in a form far greater than you could
ever imagine when your primary focus is
happiness everybody who's successful and
by successful I mean like absolutely
fulfilled in their career you know
passionate about it and feeling like
they're doing something that they're
supposed to do they have these three
characteristics and first of all they
have joy they're happy in their work
they enjoy what they do most of the time
they're not doing a soul-sucking job if
they have a job it's a great job or if
it's something that they built for
themselves they really enjoy it and the
second quality is money because there's
lots of things you can do that you enjoy
but if you don't get paid for them then
it's a hobby
which is great like it's good to have a
hobby but if you're talking about a
career it has to be financially
sustainable so joy money and then the
third factor is flow which is really
doing something that you're good at
really doing something where when you do
it you're immersed in it and the hours
just kind of passed by and it's also
really easy for you it's something that
you're good at and other people are like
wow like you know she's really good at
that takes me a lot longer to do that or
I'm not good at it but so I think what
we're looking for is this combination of
all three factors we want something that
brings joy we want something that is
financially sustainable we want
something that brings flow and I don't
think people will be happy unless they
have all three of these factors yeah I
think you can be a little bit hot you
can be okay
right there's lots of people who do jobs
they don't love and that's fine they get
a paycheck and you know maybe they're
satisfied in other areas of their life
but because life is short why not try to
work toward something you know that is
not just you know okay but is amazing
right isn't that the goal it's easy to
let the pressures of life weigh us down
we have traffic to deal with bills to
pay people that are rude if we're not
careful we'll look up and we don't smile
as much we're not as friendly we never
laugh never have fun anymore we have too
much pressure too much responsibility to
enjoy life but God didn't create you to
live with the heaviness you're not
supposed to go around solemn serious all
the time
burdened down by problems taking time to
laugh to have fun that we energizes you
it helps keep you in balance if it's all
work all stress all dealing with
problems that's going to weigh you down
and you can get so busy raising your
children changing diapers getting them
to school making sure their homework is
done that you don't enjoy your children
to all work no time for play and
sometimes we think we have to be serious
to show that we're responsible but you
can be responsible and good-natured at
the same time have you let the pressures
of life weigh you down or you always
solemn always see
if you don't make this adjustment not
only will you not enjoy your life to the
fall but you won't have good
relationships nobody wants to be around
a grumpy sour person that pushes people
away full volume you have the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple that would be
like a little beacon hey believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details